hey guys ryan right here Jerry we got
some surprising news today well you
can't say it's surprising you can say
it's rather expected of visuality we hit
50,000 subscribers so we just got here
today to say thank you thank you guys
for supporting the channel for
subscribing if you're new stick around
it's gonna be fun yeah don't touch that
dial don't touch that dial or real
rejects right after these messages from
our sponsor yes so we thought today we
would cover some stuff cover the top
complaints about the real rejects that's
what we possibly do for number one we
have not replying back to comments
that's the big one Jake oh hey whoa
might be Jesus why'd you reply to my
comment sorry Jesus it's apparently I
this is upsetting people because we're
like what happened to the days where you
would always reply back there's a lot
more comments now than before we
actually did have this conversation a
few times a while goes like at a certain
point they're like you know you have so
many hours in a day and there are so
many cup like at least you're like like
my videos get like seven comments I've
one spent like a full hour and I got
like half of a day done of like a day of
the comments as I go and order yeah
today I'm ton you guys it's not it's not
so easy me to use uber it's not so easy
it's hard to reply to just mountains of
gum is hard it's time consuming it's
like I don't have time on my hands today
know if people if certain sentiments
should become similar like you don't
want to write the same answer 500 times
so like you want me yeah personalized
and it takes time I feel like button a
lot I hit the like button on most
comments and I reply that to the ones
that I feel really deserve a reply it's
like either you get a video every day or
two or like one video a week and every
coming is yet yeah at a certain point
there's a give-and-take mmm and so it
makes it more rewarding when you
actually get a comment back now ya
because ya the system is growing is this
natural growing pain it's just we're
just tan we are just so awesome it's
ridiculous how awesome we are
these are the struggles we have well
knows you like my videos get like five
comments half of them or react to this
but I really do appreciate this
government did if I maybe if I continue
this streak I currently am going I've
actually posted like three videos in a
week maybe we'll be just as difficult
people yelling media let's find out does
Ryan smoke weed um here's what I'll
answer for that I do not smoke illegal
marijuana you like usually if he's got
some he just kind of presses it against
the the very center of his forehead
until something happens it's very weird
and he's to work it's strange to watch
it means to work I've seen it put into
like fruit smoothies and I see him like
garnish lasagnas with him I don't smoke
I don't smoke i snort it but I don't
smoke okay for the third question I was
really afraid this would happen and is
Ryan really a racist so Mike anyone who
knows me in real life knows I'm like the
last person to be a racist about it I
think racism is so stupid and that's why
I make like the most ridiculous jokes
it's obvious that I don't really mean it
it's an irony like on the Star Wars one
there was a guy there's a cup of black
actor in it and I was surprised to see
this black guy oh yeah it's a guy from
attack I'm so excited please the first
person you see and I was like oh a black
guy I wasn't expecting a black guy to be
the first person you see in the new Star
Wars movie the wrong guy was like this
is why I unsubscribe cuz Ryan is racist
especially against black Oakland know
they gotta be kidding it's obvious that
I'm like de I'm the idiot of the joke
but yeah the time like it's it's obvious
the racist looks like the idiot yeah
you're playing it satirically so it's
like it's over the time because it's
like oh I'm gonna say this really racist
thing hasn't dumb as a more downside of
my persona to highlight the fact that it
is in fact jump yes exactly I've always
said it how have you met enough people
of the same race to go I hate millions
of other people like you this one guy's
definitely an indicator for
entire group of people people who are
like every black I've ever met I'm like
that's only a handful of black people
you can dance or out of the millions
they're not all the same but all white
people to all why people yeah oh well
that's the one thing every race can get
on about wife you can this all wavy boy
okay to be raises if you're racist
against white be as Ryan boned every
girl on the channel how does he meet
these girls um I am NOT bone every girl
on the channel just one and how does he
meet these girls simple Jerry pretend to
be a girl Jerry all right you're an
actress yes dude I have a youtube
channel that's movie-related you should
totally come on to help promote yourself
I would love to yeah yeah just uh just
let me know what you I see a prime
example of that just go to Samantha
Ashley felt channel I do that with
Taylor Bradley that short it's simple so
any girls want to come on the gentleman
I'll promote themselves you just message
me let me know the fifth and last
question where's my shower um like I
said there's a lot of comments there's a
lot of requests so to make it easier
because sometimes I miss people cuz more
comments come in it's not like YouTube
just goes hey I'm gonna go back to the
exact last comment you read when you go
to this page ya know it's hard to keep
up with for the shout outs that's where
we created facebook.com slash the real
reject shout outs mmm cuz we want to
give shoutouts to you the people you get
a chef's in addition of direct
interaction with our fans what am i
doing j 00 you're reeling them in I'm
railing am in ruling and subscribers
that's having at the 50k I went fishing
now regal business so thank you guys
those are the top complaints that we
covered so that way we don't miss the
shoutout because some people have
unsubscribed in the past like two people
because they didn't get a shout-out when
they wanted I mean traditionally a
shadow is something it's like if you
need to highlight somebody like hey I
gotta give a shout out to my man Mikey
for hooking me up with those speakers we
used last episode like we don't give
typical shoutouts this is true their
personalized
they're very personalized but as such
you know their their specialty but to
get a shout-out now I would like it if
you could say something interesting and
then after a shadow or sometimes it
might just earn it it's right earn a
shout out anyway guys thank you thank
you we hope to see you in another 50
more thousand a hundred thousand guys
let's do this journey sharing is caring
it could be fun go out there post these
videos on your Twitter your Facebook
Follow us on our Facebook Twitter
Instagram vine which we don't really use
by every one day we'll release like a
DVD with all the behind-the-scenes of
how this [ __ ] gets made it's pretty
simple it's usually three lights and
camera yeah the comments out like I've
seen this man's shout out organization
process and it's pretty intense like
yeah member others a time where there's
like a hundred request yeah and I was
like holy [ __ ] like documents on various
internet windows and word searches [ __ ]
thanks man thanks man welcome your your
part you were like a I'm um I'm a humma
humma dammit dammit it's thank you and I
every I'm sits you just really like in
like him I don't know what the word is
you're just really sort of methodical a
blackberry focus yeah no holding no
you're not breastfeeding anybody recipe
mine is a wet nurse oh well let's cut
the camera right all these subscribers
are total douches Jerry I hate them I
hate all of it none of them have done
anything good for me it's a good thing
the camera is known on so that they
can't hear us trash-talking God the
camera is not on look imagine if they
were here oh just slap them on the
fillers